oh no I'm just gonna spit on the table
cuz I don't care I don't care my mouth
hurts too much to stop bacon flavored
vodka it smells like bacon dog treat
yeah whoa ah I hate vodka so much why
hey cuz it's terrible I love what good
you love Russian accent I'm salivating
like crazy like hook it up forget it
look my office just fighting it it's
like no no yogurt liqueur yogurt like a
bowling pin that has milk in it since
1575 this is older than America whoever
thought that like yogurt and liquor
sounds appealing though oh my god it
tastes like cheese that went bad I like
it that's yummy that is very good but
it's like kind of what I imagined the
consistency of semen would be I've never
seen Gabi this upset
I'm [ __ ] except when someone says women
can't do something scorpion mezcal you
get distracted by the fun hat and you
don't even notice there's a dead bug in
it excellent if I had to be killed and
put into some sort of bottle I would not
be opposed to tequila I'd want to be put
in ice cream I feel like he's actually
alive and he's gonna black gotcha
[ __ ] Oh chilly vodka I got chili
vodka like the Ark of the Covenant in
liquid form it will melt your face off
any time there's skulls on something it
means poison or danger or don't
Oh oh my god oh my god oh my god yeah
that's the worst idea
oh my stomach hates it
Oh Allison sweating and crying and her
face is red
you see probably like melt I got key if
you dip like a key initiates for your
plate where there's a character who gets
his tongue cut off I envy that character
that's the beauty of the international
community a lot of ways to get real
weird
oh you're my burp tastes like fire